[MUSIC]
Welcome, my name is Wil Torres.
I'm one of the admission officers here at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
I am so thrilled to be joined
by our panelists today.
To get started,
we're going to be talking about
the entrepreneurial resources at the GSB.
And not so much me talking about we're
going to start with a framework and
some of the different opportunities here,
and
then we're really going to get
into it with our panelists.
So at the GSB,
it's not just entrepreneurship, but
really how do we develop that
entrepreneurial spirit and
approach to the problems
you have in your everyday.
At the GSB, there's over 60 courses that
have some element of entrepreneurship
embedded into them.
And there's five different pillars for
how we approach entrepreneurship.
Looking through the offerings
of our Center for
Entrepreneurial Studies,
as well as Center for Social Innovation.
This comes to life in so
many different ways on campus.
And today, we're going to be joined by
three of our either current students or
alumni who can speak to
this experience firsthand.
So, with that brief intro,
which we did, we knock that out,
let's meet our panelists.
And then we'll be spending about 55
minutes together and we're going to do
everything we can to answer as many
questions as possible, all right?
So let's go ahead and meet our panelists
if we can go left to right, please.
So, Jaclyn, get us started.
Tell us a little about yourself and
what was a memorable course
that you took at the GSB?
>> Cool, thanks, Wil.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Jaclyn Chen,
I'm dialing in from New York City.
Before business school,
I worked in Financial Services.
I did investment banking and
late stage private equity investing,
also focus in financial services.
I went to Stanford because I wanted
to transition from the very buttoned
up industry of private equity into
launching something of my own.
And to be quite honest, I wasn't sure if I
had the gut to start my own company, but
I think bit by bit, and
quarter by quarter, and
taking advantage of a lot
of the resources on campus.
I decided to after business school that
I wanted to really strike out on my own.
And two years later, I'm running
a seed stage startup, we're 14 people.
The company is called Benepass and
we help companies administer, and
distribute employee benefits.
>> Jaclyn,
one of the questions that I often get,
when folks are applying to the GSB they're
interested in entrepreneurship, did you
have an idea of what you wanted to do, an
idea for that company or business already?
Or did you just know that you wanted
to lead something of your own?
>> I didn't have a specific idea.
I just thought it would be cool
to start something of my own.
I've been reading a lot about startups.
And it seemed like people had a really
incredible learning experience.
Obviously, there's a high
variability in the outcome, and
there was a path I think in which I
could have stayed in private equity.
I wasn't really sure what I wanted to do.
But being a business school I think
really solidified this path for me.
>> Shawon.
>> Hi, everyone, I am Shawon,
my pronouns are he/him and
I'm originally from
the suburbs of Chicago.
Before graduate school, I spent time in
the Dominican Republic with an education
nonprofit and then did a couple of
years of consulting with Deloitte.
And, I came into grad school because I
wanted to go back to the nonprofit sector
and was thinking about
launching my own nonprofit.
And while I was at the GSB,
I explored an idea for
a nonprofit that I am now building now in
leading full time called Vocal Justice,
and we empower black and brown youth
to become socially conscious leaders.
We are cautionary affirming
public speaking program.
Of course, that's memorable that I took
at GSB was Social Innovation practicum.
Where it was a forcing function to
actually build out this idea that I had in
my head, where every class of professors
had come in with your theory of change.
Come in with your landscape analysis,
come in with your metrics for success.
And then they brought in guest
speakers from the education space and
from the nonprofit space to give
us feedback on that content.
And my professor for that class actually
connected me to one of my biggest mentors
not who the GSB alum who's been guiding
me as I've been building Vocal Justice.
>> Nice, have there been any like moments
of feedback or advice that just like
really struck you and had you just
like open your eyes in a new way?
>> I'm like, how much time do I have?
Yes, [LAUGH] the biggest one
that I got was summer 2020,
it was the start of the pandemic.
And our motto beforehand had been me
going to school as piloting this program.
And we had a lot of success with that,
but my mentor said,
I know you want to transition to
training teachers on how to do this,
why not do that virtually right
now since everything is virtual.
I was really scared about transitioning
to that model too early, but
ended up being a huge win for
our organization.
So we now have 15 educators across the
country who facilitated our program with
their students and
we're able to go from working with like
15 to 20 students at a time to about 200.
And now we have this impact
with teachers and students.
So I'm really glad my mentor came in and
said, hey, rethink your model early on and
take advantage of the hallway that
the pandemic shifted things so
that we can reach more people.
>> Ricardo.
>> Hi, everyone, I'm Ricardo.
I am currently MBA student, will be in
my second year coming up in September.
So currently right now, I'm doing
an internship in venture capital at a firm
called FinTech Collective
out of New York City.
Before coming to do my MBA, I was
a quantitative trader at Goldman Sachs and
then I went to work at a hedge fund.
I was running a trading desk there and
then I also worked at a couple
startups and tried to start two
companies in my first year at Stanford.
And yeah, I just took full advantage
of all the resources that I could
get at the university
through the center for
entrepreneurial studies and
venture studios and all that.
I took startup garage my first year and
also took hacking for defense,
which is kind of unreal to take two of
the experiential classes in one year, but
I had a ton of fun and frankly, those
were the best experiences that I had.
Just learning from people who have been
through this time and time again and
meeting a bunch of people that are have
a lot of interesting ideas about
how the future should look and you're
trying to be kind of a driver for that.
So, yeah,
look forward to speaking with you.
>> Right, and then earlier you mentioned,
you were like trying to launch
a few things at the beginning.
You're doing VC now how did
those pieces fit together?
How have you evolved over
your time at the GSB so far?
>> Yeah, so I think for me, doing an
internship at venture capital is a way for
me to meet more entrepreneurs talk to more
individuals who are starting companies and
really get a feel for it.
How they work, how they think and how
they make decisions, how they think about
the problems that they're trying
to solve and it's been great.
I mean,
in the time that I've been doing this,
I've probably chatted like no joke
was like 100 different founders.
And that experiences has
been super beneficial.
I think for me,
it's really about trying to, I don't know,
go down one of two paths.
Either, a, try to find a way to
make venture capital industry
more beneficial for founders who
were trying to start good companies.
Or, b, like really find something
that I'm passionate about and
just dive into that, right?
>> Right, I have a feeling kind of finding
something that you love and really diving
into it Might be a theme [LAUGH] in
some way, shape or form over today's
conversation, so I'm going to stop sharing
that way we can focus on each other.
For our attendees,
please feel free to already start popping
your questions into that Q&A box.
I will be interspersing them
throughout the session and
then really diving into that
Q&A box towards the end.
Don't forget that there
is that upvote tool, so
if you see a question that you also
want to see answered, go ahead and
click that and
that will help that rise through the list.
Okay, so as we're talking about
the entrepreneurial resources,
Startup Garage and
the experiential element of it,
starting with maybe some
of the folks who took it,
can you tell us a little bit more about
Startup Garage and what that was like?
>> I can start-
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I did an unusual route of taking
Startup Garage in my first year.
So we weren't allowed to take it as
first years in the fall quarter, so
I did the winter quarter.
And I was able to do that because I had
started the company that I was working on
before even coming to the GSB.
So I already had some traction and
we had to put together a deck and
everything to display
that that was the case.
So there is an application process
if you're going through, actually,
either way,
there's an application process.
But there's an application process
you put together, effectively a deck,
which is very similar to what you would
show to a venture capital firm if you
were trying to raise capital at the time,
right?
Though it's lower stakes and
sometimes maybe, but you do get
a lot of help from the Startup Garage
community to help you put that together.
Once you get into the course,
series of ten weeks,
you get matched with a partner or
an advisor.
Our advisor was an awesome individuals,
the ex CMO of eBay and
just incredible people that
we were matched up with.
You get matched up with an operating
person to help you on the operating side
and a person to help you from the teaching
team, who also the individuals that are on
the teaching team are just incredible
experienced individuals as well.
And then you go through the process of
the lean startup methodology, right?
You go, you create hypotheses,
you do test to test them out.
The school provides resources,
we ran a couple ad campaigns,
for example, that we got resources
from the school to pay for.
We went through and built our prototypes,
and talk to a ton of people,
and got feedback, and
it was really taken seriously.
I think that the whole intention
of that class is really to
just get you to start something for
real and
connect you with people who
are going to help you be successful.
>> And then Jaclyn,
you took Startup Garages as well?
>> I did,
I was a bit more of a late bloomer.
So I took Startup Garage my second year,
I took for the first quarter and
the second quarter.
And I think what's great about
Startup Garage is that it's a mix of folks
in terms of whether or
not you're a 100% sure you're
going to start something of your own.
So I think in my team of four
people that I took the class with,
two people joined early stage
startups after business school and
one person did went into venture, and
then I'm of the four the person who
went on and actually start something.
And so I think what's great about that
class is that you get a mix of all those,
it's a big class and so everyone has
a slightly different orientation.
And so on one end of the spectrum,
you have folks who just want to
understand what that lean methodology is.
And on the other hand you have
folks who are 100% new like Ricardo
maybe that he had a specific idea in
mind and wanted to focus on that.
So that was a really great experience for
me in second year to kind of solidify
some of the early, to undo kind of
what I had been trained in.
Which is very process driven, very
buttoned up, very dot all your i's and
cross all your t's to a startup
mindset of you just try something,
you throw it out there in the world.
You get some feedback, you fix it,
you try it again, rinse and
repeat with a much higher feedback loop.
And so kind of un-orienting myself from a
previous mode of operation to this new or
scrappier side is a bit of a transition,
or at least for me,
it took a little bit of time
to get comfortable with that.
>> Yeah, and so you mentioned some of your
original group mates now they're all doing
different things.
So one question I often get is, what if
I'm not sure I want to be an entrepreneur
but I want to take the classes?
How welcoming is it, a, for folks who
are interested in the field, but also for
folks who might be dabbling or
there to learn?
Can you tell us a little
bit about that mix?
>> I think Startup Garage is very friendly
to everyone across that spectrum and
frankly people change pathway through.
So I would say one of my classmates,
I think he could have been 50 50,
and then he just decided ultimately
he didn't have one specific idea.
It didn't feel the right time in his
life to start something but he's still,
I think has in the back of his
head that he'll do it eventually.
So I think Startup Garage in
particular is very welcoming to that.
There are other resources, other
similar classes to Startup Garage and
the D school and in the engineering school
that are called either Lean Launchpad or
Launchpad, they're confusingly
named very similar things.
But those are a bit more intense
if you will, and I think for
folks who are very focused on it.
But I would say Startup Garage
is very friendly
to any front light interest
to heavy interest.
>> Yeah,
I would very much agree with that.
I think that it's like anything else
in the world that's kind of like you
get out of it what you put
into it type of situation.
And I think a lot of people go
into the process looking for
team members who will work well together.
And even if they don't necessarily
all agree on the idea or
they don't all have an idea to pursue,
I think the part of the process is
to learn how to work well in a team
in an entrepreneurial environment and
just follow whoever becomes the de
facto leader in pursuing that idea.
And I think a lot of people have
been very amenable to that and
the teaching team recognizes
that not every group that's in
the class is going to go off and
raise funds and become a startup.
So they curate the content to
make it very accessible for
folks who are going to end up being in
either at a venture capital firm or
in a corporate setting but
want to have that entrepreneurial
sort of drive as well.
>> Yes, and while we're on the topic
of experiences and courses,
Shawon there's a question from Marco here
about kind of prioritizing opportunities
especially if you're thinking about taking
classes from other places on campus.
I know you talked a little bit about
that intersection of education,
can you share a little bit
about how you approach that?
>> Yeah, so I coming into GSB know I
wanted to do one of two things afterwards,
it was either join an existing
education nonprofit or start my own.
So I decided to prioritize classes
that would help me do that.
I personally wasn't looking to explore
that many other topics outside of
education and social justice
in terms of issue area, and so
classes that were specifically speaking to
that got to the top of the list for me.
And then the other choice that I made
around prioritization was around
skill set.
So a lot of students in my class were
asking this question, should I focus more
on the harder technical skills or should
I focus on more of the soft skills like
>> Communication and team management.
And I recognized that my bread and butter
was not going to be crunching numbers or
doing financial analysis, and
that I just needed the fundamentals
when it came to that.
So I leaned more into classes that
were about how can you hire well,
how can you make sure you have equity
in terms of your company culture?
And how can you actually manage your team,
especially in a remote setting,
since I knew that might be an option for
for vocal justice.
So ended up doing lots of education,
nonprofit work and
the soft skills classes
while I was at GSB.
>> And then there's a lot of
really interesting questions.
There's a lot of interest in that,
the Startup Garage experience and
a lot of kind of experiential
places on campus.
How would you talk about
the timing of them?
Would you do that early on?
Do they come later in your second year?
I know there's a couple
different paths here, and
then also what's typical at the GSB.
Can someone share a little bit, maybe
Jaclyn, since you referenced it first,
what that timeline could look like for
folks?
>> Yeah, so
Startup Garage is commonly taken your
second year in the fall quarter.
That's the biggest class, and
then should you choose to continue,
you can continue on until winter quarter.
And then some overachievers like Ricardo
could get in winter quarter without having
done the fall quarter, which is
definitely an option but is less common.
And then I believe that engineering
school's lean Launchpad is in the winter,
quarter and then the D school's
Launchpad is in the spring quarter.
Those two classes are more
by application and
you have to have a team and
have some demonstrated, not traction,
but demonstrated experimentation
already happening.
So it does take some pre-planning
to apply in order to have
a successful application
to those two classes.
And then in the summer I did something
called Entrepreneurial Summer Program,
whereby it turned out
at seed stage company.
It was ten people in a room.
And Stanford supported part
of my compensation for
the summer to enable me to work there.
So that's the summer program,
and I think there's lots of other
resources year round as well.
>> Ricardo or Shawan, for
courses that do involve a group,
did you know the people on the outside?
What are some different ways to
help you meet people who you might
be able to work well with?
>> So I can speak to that.
So I was looking at courses that were
in the social innovation space and
the Center for Social Innovation hosted
lots of mixers, too many to keep up with,
at the start of the year.
Where you show up to the event,
you would actually get different stickers
to represent areas that you were
passionate about, whether it's education
or youth development or health care.
Put those stickers on and
then network with other people that way.
And then through some of those events, you
might meet people who want to support you
with your venture or
take a class with you.
And then when you're enrolled in some
of the social innovation classes,
they'll send out a spreadsheet
with ideas that people have and
then facilitate introductions for you if
you want to get connected to other people.
And then if you can't find a group of
people to work with within your class,
you can always talk to the professor and
pursue your own thing alone.
And they're really supportive of that,
which is what I ended up doing in my
Social Innovation practicum course.
>> There's a question here from Keyway.
And Shawan, earlier you
mentioned knowing that crunching
numbers was not necessarily going
to be your bread and butter.
And as you think about some
of the core experiences and
skill sets that a leader needs,
it's understanding your own needs versus
what what things people
on your teams can do.
And this is a question for
all three of you.
What were some skills that you
felt really comfortable with?
And what were ones that you were
looking for others to contribute?
And how did you either discover that?
Was it trial and error?
Did you already know from the outset?
And anybody can jump in on this one.
>> Yeah, one thing I would say is
just a general sense of drive to
understand the entrepreneurial
process was important,
just generally for
people to be bought into the experience.
I think that's important and that was
reflected immediately if you met somebody
that was at one of these
team formation events,
there's a good chance that they're
trying to figure that out.
And then kind of through discussion and
those events you get a sense of how
much bought into the idea they are.
The other thing I would say is
around complementary skill sets,
that was super important as well.
So I have a certain type of skill set.
And I was looking for individuals who
are kind of the opposite of me, right?
Because it doesn't make sense for
me to look for
folks that are more of me to some extent.
And that ended up working out really
well for the team that I had for
Startup Garage.
I'm not the most organized person, but
the partner that I had for Startup Garage
probably could be an amazing
logistics expert or something right?
So that ended up working out really,
really well.
>> I would say the traditional answer
I think is to to put it very bluntly,
business people want to find an engineer.
That was the common trope, if you will,
among founders and I guess the GSB class.
I attempted to at Stanford,
didn't work out for me, but
ultimately my two technical co founders
at are people through my GSB network.
So one was in my past townhouse my second
year he was the only non GSB in our house.
And then the other guy I met
through a GSBer who had known
him from a previous life.
So I think there are some people
who felt pressure, I guess,
to find the perfect person to partner with
and be a co founder with while on campus.
And I certainly felt that pressure,
but it kind of worked out for
me after the fact as
a result of the GSB network.
So that's kind of additional perspective
I would provide there in addition to what
Ricardo said.
Obviously you want people
who are interested and
aligned with kind of what you
want to put into the class.
Some of the classes I think,
in particular,
the engineering version of it and
the D school version of it.
Basically everyone has to really commit,
this is going to be your
top priority that quarter.
The same isn't necessarily true of
Startup Garage, although you could want to
put yourself in a group where all four of
you kind of are aligned on that point.
But that's a bit more on the, I guess,
soft side as opposed to like
hard skills assembling.
>> And you mentioned something really
interesting, Jac, in the network.
And so thinking about kind of we're
talking a lot about the resources during
your time at the GSB.
But your career and whether you start
entrepreneurship immediately after or
down the line or your pivot
around a couple different places.
That's like a lifelong path.
So, maybe starting with Shawan and
Jaclyn, now that you're out,
how have the Stanford network
supported you in this endeavor and
then Ricardo as a current student,
are you experiencing that as well?
And how are the outside post GSB
family members helping you out?
So maybe we can start with Shawan, since-
>> Yeah.
>> So,
I am grateful that I have a fellowship
through this Center for Social Innovation,
Social Innovation Fellowship, that
supports early stage social entrepreneurs.
And through that I get a coach who works
for the Center for Social Innovation.
And I meet with her every two
weeks to walk through my idea.
And so that's been incredible
as I'm building an organization,
hiring my first employee, to have Somebody
who's affiliated with that team to just
give me real proton feedback and
be a sounding board for me.
And then the alumni network
is also incredible.
I have not tapped into it enough because
I'm still breathing after graduating just
a few months ago.
But I know that there are tons of
listservs with entrepreneurs affiliated
with venture studio at Stanford that you
can blast out to if you need advice on
anything as the emails
coming into it all the time.
And so as I'm getting ready to
do fundraising in the future and
building off the organization more
definitely I'm going to be cold emailing
a lot of GSB alumni.
I've heard from friends that the response
rate is really high when you contact
somebody far from the network.
>> Yeah, just the network is very strong
in my entrepreneurship life, I think
had I not gone to the GSB I don't think
I would have ended up down this path.
I would say in terms of kind of,
so my co-founders aren't GSBs, but
like I said, I met them through my GSB
network like one connection removed.
I am in a kind of CEO support group
of what among founders in our class,
and all of us have.
Some of us are doing venture backed
startups, other folks did search fun.
So kind of the different types of
the different flavours of entrepreneurship
that we'll had mentioned
early on the slides.
And then in addition,
I've also taken venture funding
from folks in the GSB network.
Several classmates are on my cap table, so
there's kind of that
financial support as well.
And so yeah,
definitely the network brings so much or
it has brought at least so much to
my experience with entrepreneurship.
It's everywhere and
it's definitely been a huge help today.
>> And I would just say, while you're
a student, it's still massively impactful.
I would say the reason I have the
internship I have is because of an MBA2
that was the intern the previous
year at the same firm.
And the connections that
I had through them and
the kind of insight that I had about
the firm and kind of the process and
the people and everything that was shared
through having that person in my network.
And then in addition to that, I would
say it's just having being at the GSB,
especially in the time that you're there
to Shawn's point earlier the response
rate that you get on emails to individuals
that you reach out to is incredibly high,
right?
So of 150 emails that I sent out to VCs,
I had chats with probably 50
of them right, which is crazy.
And some of these are partners that
are really important firms and
those experiences are what
have allowed me to be able to
have the insights that I have now really,
right?
And so without that it would be very
difficult to have done that without
having had a background in venture
entrepreneurship before coming to the GSB.
>> Yeah, I think we're kind
of alluding to this already.
But maybe if we can distill
even further and take them on,
we're going to jump into the Q&A box.
There's a question here from
Chagnon about comparing,
if you were to go into
entrepreneurship without an MBA.
How does your GSB experience
bring some unique values or
kind of perspectives to the things
that you're interested in?
So take a moment, versus no MBA,
or with a now the GSB
experience, how do you
think it's different?
Where's the value in pursuing the MBA
if you're thinking about going
into entrepreneurship?
This is for anybody on the panel.
>> I can kick it off.
And so a couple things come to mind.
First, I think that Stanford
teaches entrepreneurship
in a way that's about the process as
opposed to about a specific idea.
And I think that is something
that was a mindset shift.
That was pretty strong for
me because I always thought
these people started a company
because they had one specific idea.
And until I got to better pass I recycled.
There are many, many,
a graveyard of ideas, if you will.
And this one worked out because
of a series of testing,
talking to customers,
prototyping that whole process.
And I think, again,
you can probably read a book and
understand it's not rocket science.
But at the same time getting to put
it into practice with mentors along
the way is the value of being
in a school environment.
And then the second thing I'd
say is that around the network,
absolutely kind of already
touched upon that already.
And that's a huge help to
building your business over time.
And then after a certain point and I feel
I'm currently making this transition.
Now is we are a seed stage company,
we're going to grow and now my job has
quickly transitioned from being just
a scrappy early stage get things done
as quickly as possible to transitioning
to be a leader of my company.
And there are a lot of things that,
I mean, I'm not making the transition
perfectly, but those are different
jobs and different functions.
And so I think a lot of entrepreneurs
perhaps without their MBA can kind of
chance into because they have a great
idea and it just starts taking off.
But you might not have the foundational
skills around how to be a good leader,
how to be a good communicator,
how to build team morale,
all these things are really crucial
to make your company become a bigger
company that's going to
stand the test of time.
And so that final piece of the skill
set is absolutely something that I
learned at Stanford and
continue to put into practice.
And I don't think I would have I mean,
again, I could read a book, but
I don't think it would have sunk in as
much as it did had I not gone to the GSB.
>> See lots of head nods from the panel.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, I would just add to that,
I think that the sort of being
able to have the time to test and
try things out was super critical, right?
So you're spending two years here that you
would otherwise be spending at work or
whatever and you'd be super busy.
I can't tell how much time I've had to
be able to reflect on kind of myself and
the experiences that I have.
And also try a lot of different things
out in different industries and
different areas of knowledge that I
wouldn't have had time to explore before.
And I think what that does for
the entrepreneurial experiences really
just allow you to do that testing
without kind of any unforeseen kind
of losses or potential losses.
And allows you to,
Jacly's point to kind of really,
really understand the process and
not really have to be focused
on the idea itself generally.
>> And I'd add two things to that one,
there's a joke at GSB that everybody has
been a startup founder is thinking
about being one will be one, one day.
And so you're just surrounded by people
who understand that world which, for
me was really helpful to build my
confidence when it came to pitching.
There's so many of my friends who
were saying, you should ask for
even more money for
yourself for the organization.
And this is how you tactically can go
about doing it, because they understand
what it's like to put yourself out there
and the importance of making a big ask.
And I think because I learned that
from people who are a part of this
entrepreneurship world, they helped us to
secure more funding for the organization.
And then the second piece is building
on what Ricardo was saying that
Not only do you have the space
to reflect on ideas, but
you also can get some funding to do so.
The Center for
Social Innovation has a fellowship called
the Impact Design Immersion Fellowship.
For people who want to explore ideas
in the social innovation space between
their first and second year at GSB.
And I did that fellowship and
got funding thankfully for
ten weeks to explore this idea,
talk to students about their experience,
connect with with school leaders.
And that was awesome just
to learn more about it and
that's not something I could have
done if I were working full time,
both because I didn't have the time
to do it or the money to support it.
>> There's a question here from we've
focused a lot on kind of experience.
And my suspicion is most of your work
is here in the US kind of domestically,
but maybe it's in other experiences or
things that your classmates have done.
Are there resources for
people looking at startups aiming to
address issues in other countries?
Any insights on that would be awesome.
>> Well, first and foremost, I think
the package that you get if you say that
you have a startup and you're a Stanford
student from the Stanford venture
studios is blind to where you're
operating, just first and foremost.
All of the resources that they
put through, for example,
like connecting you to lawyers or
accountants and things like that.
They often will make a point to do
things for specific industries and
specific regions.
So they would do things for social
innovation, for example specifically, but
then also for
international things as well.
So they do have a lot of content that
they cater specifically for that.
>> Has anybody seen maybe classmates
trying to launch things internationally or
you heard anything from that front?
>> Yeah, there's a company
from my class called Ajaib,
which is a robo-advisor in Indonesia.
I think overall, it's a process,
not the idea, and
that also applies to whether it's US or
international.
At the end of the day,
you're trying to solve a problem or
a pain point as it's called.
And that exists everywhere
in many different forms.
So it's more about the process
as opposed to a specific idea.
>> And so kind of on that similar
theme of process versus idea.
Are folks able to apply the process
to an idea they had before the GSB
in some of these classes, or are these
ideas that had stuff come up at the GSB?
>> Can definitely be something you had
before GSB or came up with at GSB.
I had my idea of a similar version before.
Actually when I was applying to GSB,
I remember writing about in my application
and then when I got to GSB I just
started exploring it through coursework.
Other people set up weekly chats with
friends to just brainstorm a ton of
ideas and then decide which one they
want to explore while they're there.
>> My friend Chad Monroe from my class,
runs a startup called Jupiter
with two of our classmates now.
When he first got to campus,
I think the original format of his idea
was shipping things from
the US outside via.
To bring goods that weren't otherwise
accessible outside the US and
now it's a last mile grocery
delivery company and
that evolution kind of took
place while we were at the GSB.
And en route he got,
two other GSB co founders and
an engineer from an undergrad I think.
So anyway all that is to say
you can definitely start early,
bring people along, look for
people to join you on your ride,
your idea will probably change.
And international or US I think
that's all the world is your oyster.
>> Question about funding.
So getting resources and
funding is going to be a big part
of the entrepreneurial journey.
There's a question from Joshua,
about resources to help you pitch to
venture capitalists for seed funding.
Any experiences on that front?
>> I mean, I would argue that the winter
quarter of Startup Garage is designed
help you design your pitch deck,
that's the unsaid kind of intention.
And at the end of that class you
do actually get to pitch live
to a couple of venture capitalists
that are invited by the teaching team.
And when I say a couple I
don't mean two or three,
I mean there was ten of them there, right?
And they're all very related to the area
that you're looking to raise from.
And from that class there have been a lot
of people who have gone forward and
raised capital.
I had the same exact experience
in hacking for defense.
At the end a bunch of people pitched
some people actually got funded, right?
So the resources are there and
same thing with Stanford Venture Studios.
Throughout the year, they'll put out
a lot of resources that you can go and
look at yourself, to go look at examples
and walkthroughs and things like that.
But you can also sit down with a VC or
an entrepreneur, and go through your deck.
We did that on multiple occasions and got
a ton of good feedback from individuals.
>> And Shawan you mentioned,
you're talking about a mentor.
Ricardo, you mentioned a mentor
in one of your other classes.
Do these kind of relationships
come up organically?
Are they mostly things that come through
structured formats and classrooms?
How have you seen mentorship,
advisory sponsor relationships
kind of develop across campus?
>> For me, it was pretty organic.
My professor reached out and said, hey, I
wrote a book about founders of nonprofits.
Do you want to connect with this one?
And I said, yes, of course I do.
And we had a call, we hit it off and
then he sent me a really kind of email
afterwards and so I was like, okay,
this person seems incredible.
His name's Ray Cyrus and
I wanted to learn from him since his
nonprofit has done great work in
the education opportunity space.
And so I just asked him, hey,
do you want to be my mentor for
the summer while I'm exploring this idea,
and he agreed, and
then we just continued
working together from there.
I think other people might do
some cold emails to find mentors
in a more formal sense, but for me it was
just organically talking to people and
then see who you connect with and
going from there.
>> Yeah, so there are formal processes for
it that I went through and
Startup Garage and Hacking for Defense
where you get matched up with a mentor.
Those are also hit or miss, just like
in normal life, if you go out and
try to find a mentor, it can work
sometimes and sometimes it doesn't.
We were fortunate that one
of the folks that was one of
our mentors was amazing and
we hit it off and the sessions were great.
But there were examples when
that wasn't quite the case.
So there are a lot of examples
that are more structured, but
there are to Shawann's point.
Probably the person who's helped me
the most is somebody that I reached out
to via cold email.
I talked to a whole bunch of people but
that person was the one that
I connected with the most.
And I just kept having more questions for
and kept connecting with.
And they agreed to and they provided all
sorts of guidance and things like that.
I think it can happen
very organically as well.
Just if you're willing to be coached,
you'll find someone.
>> Jaclyn, here's a question for you.
How did you think about
the cost of the MBA?
So we're taking a whole left turn here
kind of coming back to the beginning of
the journey.
How did you think about the cost of the
MBA, including opportunity cost of living,
lucrative career, finance, In the context
of wanting to start a company,
how did you kind of
approach that mentally?
>> Yeah, I'm not doing a startup because
I think it's going to make me a ton
of money.
I mean, that would be great as a side
effect, but the reason I'm doing it
is I think it's the best conduit for
personal and professional growth.
The actual content, I deal with IRS
rules on taxability of benefits.
When I was five years old, I did not
dream, it's not like going to space,
that was not my dream.
But the lessons learned along the way are
why I wanted to do it to start with and
that's what sustains me when
things get really tough.
And your first five or ten customer calls
and they tell you your idea's not great,
or they would never buy it or
whatever it is,
I think that's that's what
sustains me through it.
So I didn't think of starting
a company in a rational way,
I would say that you're presenting it
that way, it was never for me about that.
I think even if I had taken the money
I invested in my MBA and said,
I'm going to put it in a bank account and
start spending that money.
I don't think I would have had a clue on
how to actually do that in a good way.
And like I said, I didn't have an idea.
I didn't have a process.
I didn't have a cofounder.
So those are other very important
ingredients other than money for
really to start something of your own.
So I guess, yeah, my answer is like
I didn't think about it in that way.
And if you have a fully
fleshed out idea and
all you really need is
capital to make it work.
Yeah, I mean,
I think you can make the case for that.
But for me it was about getting the other
ingredients for starting a company.
>> And here's a question from Michael.
Thinking about opportunities
to continue working or
launching something outside of
the classroom during the academic year.
Is that possible?
How do you juggle your time?
Were you continuing to work on your ideas
outside of the classroom after those
classes have been over?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah, sorry.
Yeah, certainly,
I think it's kind of you manage
your own time the way that you want to and
you kind of prioritize things
as you see fit, right?
I think you are advised not to
work at a startup while you're
doing your MBA, but
there are people that do it, right?
So people have done it and they have great
experiences and kind of learned a lot and
have a lot of personal growth.
And then there's tons of people
that are working on ideas,
whether they're doing it
through coursework or not, and
they spend a lot of time
outside of school doing that.
And being around your classmates
helps quite a bit in terms of
breaking down barriers that you're
facing and all that as well.
>> Yeah, that hits on a lot of
what I was going to bring up.
It is hard to work on your idea and
also be a student and have a social life.
But I think if you come in and
you say this is what I want to do, and
I know I'm committed to at least
explain the idea, you'd block the time
on your calendar before somebody else
sends you an invite for an event.
And for me it was worth it.
I said no to a lot of stuff at GSB so I
could be off campus, going to schools, and
pilot my idea.
But in the long run in line with
what I wanted to do after GSB and
I still had time to make good friends and
have fun and all of that.
So it's not like you sacrifice everything,
you just have to be
a bit more intentional.
The other thing is that there are a lot of
classes where you can work on your venture
and do things for the class.
So, basically, any class that I was in,
I found a way to tie typical justice.
So I was in winning writing that
was a communications course,
I would have my pitches
be about Vocal Justice.
Or my nonprofit management class, I would
do research on a competitor that I needed
to research anyway for Vocal Justice.
And so it ends up being less work in the
end, since you have a dual purpose for it.
>> Then Shawan,
did you do a low keynote as well?
[LAUGH]
>> Yes, I did low keynote,
which is a nine minute talk on
the issue you care about and
mine was related to Vocal Justice.
It was on public speaking and
critical consciousness and
I use that now to promote
the organization.
>> These are also accessible.
So if you go to YouTube and
search low keynotes,
you can also see what that looks like.
So encourage folks to
check that out as well.
And Jaclyn, did you pop off?
Did you have a?
>> Nope, nothing
>> Awesome, and so
we're talking about
intentionality with time.
I think that can also be
an intentionality with opportunities.
Question from Jay is how did you
balance driving towards that idea
versus staying open and
exploring other things?
Any advice to someone who's
grappling with that same tension?
>> I think by being around classmates
who are doing lots of different things,
you're by default kind of open.
Just from lunchtime,
dinnertime conversation,
what's everyone interested in,
what's everyone focused on?
And so you'll just learn by default a lot
of what other pursuits could look like.
So guess, for me, I felt like it was very
clear what the different flavors of and
if anything, I could draw
inspiration from my classmates of
how they were pursuing it and their way.
That gave me ideas on how I
might inform my own process.
>> Yes.
>> One thing I would
just add there quickly,
as long as you're committed to sort
of either being an entrepreneur or
joining a startup,
I think things become way easier.
Because if you are also trying to recruit
for consulting and PE, then things
become more difficult because you're
basically recruiting the entire year.
But if you commit to kind of
being either an entrepreneur or
going to work at a startup then you
have a ton of time to explore, right?
You don't have to commit
to something immediately.
Or if you do commit to something for
a month, and
you decide to pivot at the end of that,
then it's not a waste of time because
you still have more months to go, right?
So I wouldn't be too concerned about that.
It's more just making
the decision between am
I going to go the traditional
kind of consulting PE route?
Or am I going to go
the entrepreneurship startup route?
>> And we're getting close to time.
And so I'm going to go ahead and
claim this last question.
As you're thinking,
words of wisdom to a younger you,
whether it's in the application process,
it's during your time at the GSB.
Maybe it's just as you graduated.
As you're venturing out onto this
whole new brave world ahead.
What advice would you give to yourself?
So, take a moment and then maybe,
Ricardo we could start with you and
Shawan then Jaclyn to take us home.
>> Yeah, I would say I mean first and
foremost, breathe, right?
It's a bit of a long process and
it's super fun.
It's really transformative from
a personal and educational perspective.
You're going to meet a ton
of amazing people who you
never thought you would be kind
of rubbing elbows with and stuff.
But just breathe for now and
just know that the the world's
going to be your oyster.
Once you're here you're going to have
tons of opportunities to meet people,
have conversations you'd never thought
you'd have and learn topics that you'd
never thought you'd kind of be diving into
>> Okay, Shawan.
I would say take time for
yourself and I think there
are two ways to think about that.
One is just time for you to breathe,
relax, binge watch the show on Netflix.
Because entrepreneurship journey is hectic
and so you got to just take that time and
be diligent about taking care of yourself.
But the other way I think about
that is time for introspection.
I think a lot of my best thinking comes
when I'm just sitting by myself for
a couple of hours and free writing about
why I'm doing the work that I'm doing.
What my values are,
what some of my concerns are, and
how I want to get better.
And it's really hard to make that time
on your own if you're just go, go,
go with your venture.
And so being diligent about having
that time maybe every two weeks,
every month to have some
introspection thing is important.
>> Awesome and then,
Jacqueline, taking us home.
>> Well, the first, Ricardo and
Sean's answers were both really good.
It's all going to be fine.
I would say have a plan and be patient.
So I think for me having a few areas of
focus helped me make easier decisions
given just the wealth of things
you could be doing at the GSB.
And your calendar will be booked
end to end and probably double book
because there's so many cool
things that you want to be doing.
And so you need some level of focus
of what you want your experience
to be oriented around, a few things, and
really spend time on those two things.
And then finally, I would say I think one
sense of feeling I have is like, I see so
and so doing this and
that's really taking off or
I see so and so doing this and
that's really taking off.
And I think in hindsight having a bit
more patience with myself that for
me my entrepreneurship journey
bloomed kind of post business school.
And I wasn't one of the ones that kind
of came in with a clear vision in mind.
But it still kind of worked out
the way that it was meant to work out.
So be patient and have a plan.
>> Wonderful, so breathe, take time for
yourself, be patient, have a plan.
These are [LAUGH] all really
wise words to live by.
Definitely stuff that I'm going to be
applying to my own life even though I'm
not in entrepreneurship at the moment.
But with that, thank you so
much to our panelists who took your
time out today to spend with us.
For those of you in my audience,
if you haven't done so already,
I would definitely encourage you
to jump onto MyStanford.mba.
You can create a dashboard there and
with a few questions,
we'll be able to help collect ideas,
events that might be of interest to you.
Speaking of events,
beginning of August second through sixth,
we are hosting an application week to
help you better understand the process.
And so in doing that,
to help you put your best foot forward,
there was some a lot of
themes about process.
And hopefully that is one place that
we're going to be able to dig into that
even more deeply.
With that, thank you again for
joining us and
we hope to see you across other
events this summer, stay safe.
Hope to see you soon.
[MUSIC]